je dis pas que vous parlez beaucoup hein
mais vous avez un bon débit hein [__]
mais si non non je parle
trop magnifique magnifique magnifique
robe mer bonjour Thierry Talia peut se
faire du souci là je vais te dire ah si
si il y a du monde là
mer alors Clémentine s dit voilà je
viens chez Ardisson il va me parler de
cul pas du tout on va parler de tes
nichons comment ça va tu es magnifique
c'est de qui cette robe là merci c'est
Vivien Westwood ah ah bah bien sûr c'est
chouette elle fait des trucs c'est la
première fois que que je porte une robe
qu'elle m'a prêté et tout enfin elle
enfin les personnes qui travaillent pour
elle et tout et je la remercie beaucoup
parce que c'est vraiment ben nous aussi
on remercie Vian Westwood alors
Clémentine est-ce que votre père regarde
oui oui non bah oui bah oui forcément
non mais bon il m'a dit quand
tiierardisson te demande des choses
sexuelles ma chérie dis-lui que c'est
des choses intimes que tu n'as pas
forcément à partager avec tout le monde
c'est VO parce qu'il aime pas il aime
pas quand vous parlez de ça he V non
mais il y a pas que lui quelque fois des
amis va ouais j'ai la trouille c'est
bizarre ce soir c'est pouro je sais pas
parce que vous avez votre émission elle
a elle s'est épanouie quoi un côté c'est
vrai elle est pas qu'elle a un peu copié
mon
émission demand
au ça veut dire qu'elle est bonneelle
est bien alors justement on va rester
sur votre père parce que il travailleit
à la télé oui il était rédacteur en chef
pour pour TF1 et c'est un type très
intègre votre père il était très choqué
par les meurs de la télé et vous dites
souvent il rentrait malheureux le soir à
la maison
j'ai ce souvenir là oui quelquefois pas
tout le temps mais qu'il était un peu
déchiré par oui et puis c'était pas
quelqu'un qui reconstituait l'actualité
pour que ce soit plus sensationnel plus
dramatique et connaître quoi et alors
vous dites vous suite à toute cette
expérience que vous avez vécu avec votre
père vous dites la télévision est un
métier monstrueux où être malhonnête
n'est pas grave
oui enfin je sais pas ça doit être
difficile de de rester vraiment intègre
de de faire vraiment ce qu'on veut SF qu
mê temps c'est du spectacle mais c'est
vrai qu'on essaie de de dire la vérité
com
amant bien alors vous vous avez fait
beaucoup de concessions dans votre
carrière pour y arriver bah non pas
assezoup sinon je je je feraai du cinéma
jeis pas non non je dire je m'en fous
c'est pas grave alors au début pourtant
vous avez accepté très facilement de de
changer de nom non quand vous estêes
arrivé à à Radio 7ouappelle merem en
vrai bah ouais Patrick meer vous a
demandé de vous appeler Clémentine vous
AZ dit oui tout de suite pas de problème
he oui parce que c'était pour parce que
je rigolait il disait voà làsus vous
avez été assez ou m'en foutais actriceà
et heureusement vous avez pas gardé le
nom que benex vous avez donné dans 372
parce que vous vous souvenez du surnom
de benex non je sais plus c'était quoi
non je dirais pas en général dis ça
c'est que tu vas le
dire chais Porcinet ah pardon c'est un
autre c'est sympa sympa oui mais bon
sympa
porsinette non alors donc vous étiez au
départ prête à faire certaines
concessions en tous les cas changeer
votre nom assez rapidement et puis après
non et puis après c'était fini par
exemple quand Yv monant vous a sauté
dessus au standard de Radio France pour
moi le le le sexe est lié à l'amour hein
donc c'est quelqu'un qui vous drague
comme ça mais en plus je respecte c'est
un homme absolument génial mais après
vous vous admirez une une espèce d'image
vous savez quelqu'un de et puis après
vous voyez que c'est un homme enfin je
veux dire il a bon il vous a dit qu'il
pouvait vous aider euh oui oui benah oui
parce qu'il voulait oui oui oui mais bon
ça se fait ça je peux t'aider petite et
puis en fait il y avait une [__] dans la
tête ou quoi oui mais ça c'est enfin
c'est fréquent ENF un jour j'ai dit un
truc je vis juste rétablir quelque chose
j'ai dit un truc très vulgaire très
grossier c'est pas chez moi hein par que
c'est pas le genre de l'émission hein
j'ai dit bon je va me faire un peu
engueuler c'est pas grave j'ai dit qu'il
fallait sucer des bits pour arriver dans
le cinéma ouais ce que je voulais dire
par là c'est que moi je n'ai pas fait ça
et je pense qu'il est il est tout à fait
déplacé que ce soit enfin avec ça qu'
qu'on doiv enfin qu'on que ce soit grâce
à ça qu'on arrive à faire du cinéma
enfin c'est pas que grâce à ça je pense
c'était vous parliez pour vous en fait
alors vous parliez pour les autres voilà
c'est ça ou c'est rétabli ce soir devant
des millions de gens non en fait
sérieusement votre refus des concessions
Clémentine vous a mis dans une position
assez marginale dans le métier
finalement oui c'est pas génial hein ou
en fait ça a commencé à l'école à
l'école vous dites quand vous en parlez
de votre cette période vous dites déjà
j'étais trop grande trop encombrante
avec un ne boxeuse alors que je rêvais
d'être diaphane et névrosé oui j'avais
envie d'être je sais pas jolie enfin
fine voyez je pas fille vous êtes très
jolie arrêtez quand oui non mais merci
mais maintenant d'abord je suis une
femme vous voyez j'étais une femme avant
avant j'ai jamais été une jeune fille
voyez c'est pour ça enfin j'ai r ét
formé très jeune
racontez-moi parce que mais on a parlé
de elle c'était 9 ans
an et alors vous dites c'est la même
chose aujourd'hui parce que dans ce
métier aujourd'hui je me sens souvent un
peu au fond de la classe près du
radiateur oui oui oui vraiment oui en ce
moment au cinéma je je oui je comprends
pas
mais pasisent heureuse ce j'ai de évs
Vière dis voilà ça c'est mais c'est le
pied et mais mais il y a des moments où
il y a un an je me tapis des crises de
cafard terrible vraiment mais parce que
je comprenis pas mais bon c'est pas
grave ce que jeis vous dire le public
pourquoi parce que des fois vous êtes un
peu démesuré non vous trouvez pas c'est
votre façon de faire les choses à fond
Clémentine si j'avais su plutôt que
j'étais comme ça que ce sera comme ça
j'aurais peut-être plus vite fait mon
chemin tout seul vous voyez et pu
peut-être peut-être vous a été plus
mystérieuse un peu comme Catherine de
neuve très comme ça la fille qui dit
rien voilà comme ça voilà parle
doucement tout ça non vous êtes très
marginal en fait j'ai j'ai lu dans un
journal que vous passiez votre temps
dans les boîes Gay j'aime beaucoup al
pas de vous marier là c'est quoi cette
histoire Clémentin mais je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'aime les boîes Gay je sais
pas parce que je me sens je me sens en
fait libre parce que j'ai l'impression
que il y a pas tous ces trucs alors la
drague et puis le machin et puis non
mais
oui mais quoi quefin oui bien non alors
donc pourquoi Clémentine sélarier n'est
pas mariée pourquoi n'est-elle pas marié
d'abord bon elle passe beaucoup de temps
dans les boîtes gay on vient de le dire
et puis c'est vrai non c'est vrai que
vous faites une idée très très midinette
du mariage complètement c'est monstrueux
att tros comment ça se fait ça ah ben ça
je sais pas il faudra demander je sais
pas oui pour moi c'est le truc absolu
passionnel tous les gens qui me disent
oui mais bon je suis très entière
forcément donc disent mais tu c'est
impossible j'en ai absolument fait ça
m'intéresse pas ce genre de discours je
suis pas j'ai pas l'impression de
d'avoir j'en suis pas là enfin je veux
dire j'ai pas mais je crois qu'il y a
vous comptez quand même vous marier un
jour quand même ah je veux me marier ah
oui je veux me marier lanc un appel là
non pourquoi vous cherchez quoi non mais
vous cherchez quoi comme type
d'homme j'ai fait exprès
oh non mais j'ai fait exprès oh on a
marié vous savez qu'ici on a marié la
Rousseau on a marié la Rous sais entendu
ça non mais la Rousseau est venue ici un
jour désespéré elle av plus de jus tout
ça et on a lancé un appel elle a trouvé
Fabrice quoi Fabrice mais qui de la
classebri cel qui
habitearin connais pas je suis pas alors
il y a un truc vous supportez pas aussi
c'est l'enterrement de V jeune fille non
mais cette idée
alors mais l'idée de toute façon ça
l'idée d'enterrer quelque chose pour se
marier est-ce que vous imaginez ça
abominable et alors moi si je me
marie jeune fille déjà pour commencer
mais je veux dire je je non mais non non
mais je me sentirai vierge et purure
pour l'homme que j'aim jolie c'est
beau alors il y a un problème moi moi
j'ai j'ai trouvé en fait pourquoi vous
mariez pas c'est parce que vous refusez
d'assister au mariage ça vous fait chier
les mariages ça oui pas vous sa que
c'est dans les mariages les statistiques
le prouvent c'est dans les mariages
qu'on rencontre les gens avec qui on va
se marier ah mais il faut que j''y aille
autre cause de votre marginalité l'clec
V vous dites je n'ai pas de carrière ce
que je fais c'est ma vie je vois pas
pourquoi il faut réduire vous dites le
théâtre pour moi c'est sacré oui c'est
sacré parce que c'est un endroit c'est
une bulle et c'est un endroit il y a des
moments où j'ai envie que que d'être là
en dehors de mes enfants je pas faire la
plintive mais en dehors de mes enfants
en fait il y a que là que je suis bien
quoi bah oui dans le truc
bidon comment on fait avec les mains là
comment comment on fait avec les mains
donc voilà vous interprétez madame sans
jeè c'est une pièce de Victorien Sardou
là c'est la version de Pierre Laville
mise en scène donc par Alain sax alors
elle a vraiment existé cette Mame sans
gène hein c'est le mélange de deux
femmes qui existé voilà il y il y a la
femme du maréchal Lefèvre ex
blanchisseuse qui a été d'une fidélité
sans faille à son mari et à Napoléon et
puis une une fille de Pontoise aussi qui
s'appelait vraiment madame sansè donc on
a mélangé on a mélangé les deux alors le
rôle a quand même déjà été joué par
Réjane mistinguette Jean sour Sophie des
maris harletti et même Sophia Loren oui
aussi qui a interprété le rôle au cinéma
alors au départ vous vous trouvez l'idée
un peu trop évidente he quand oui je
voulais je voulais pas et puis c'est
quelqu'un qui a compé dans ma vie qui
m'a dit qui m'a dit tu tu étais fol de
et tout d'un coup j'ai eu je me suis dit
oui et donc j'ai j'ai appelé mon agent
Laurent Grégoire qui est un ami et puis
voilà et puis puis on l'a fait on a dit
on le fait et puis en fait un an s'est
passé et moi pendant ce tempsl j'ai
écrit mon one man show je voulais faire
one man show enfin spectacle toute seule
et puis et puis j'étais à la lecture au
Théâtre Antoine mais vraiment harculon
je voulais plus faire mais du tout et
puis et puis il s'est passé un truc dans
ce
théâtre incroyable mais mais tout d'un
coup j'avais l'impression de de lire
enfin mes mots enfin bon et puis tout le
monde du th madame sang non mais
évidemment que c'est vous oui mais c'est
vrai c'est le 18 octobre donc au Théâtre
Antoine c'est pas une comédie musicale
que comme je chante aussi il y a des
gens qui mélangent
tout
[Musique]
vous passez éidemment de Madame sans gne
à ça ça c'est Charles chillings et
pompon F donc c'est quand même ouais
vousz rencontré comment dans une boîte
gay aussi lui oui à la démence le Fuse à
Bruxelles et c'était génial ça c'est
mais pour moi c'est c'est extra qui ces
deux trucs là tu vois je me dis queame
sans jeune elle vivrait maintenant
je pense que elle aurait peut-être aussi
rencontré Charles quoi Charles shings on
s'est rencontré dans cette boîte
j'entendais le son qu'il faisait
j'aimais bien faire des impros à Vaison
j'ai des copains tout ça qui ont des
boîtes et tout ça et puis et puis là je
me suis dit je lui dis tu as confiance
en moi tu as un micro tout ça j'aimais
bien faire des impros un peu avec des DJ
et là bah depuis c'est comme si on était
marié alors lui c'est comme un genre de
mais non on n'est pas ensemble il est
très beau magnifique mais il ne veut pas
de moi non non mais je rigole non mais
je rigole pourquoi je dis des conneries
comme ça non non non mais c'est
mais non mais il est c'est un mec génial
qui dégage vous voyez comment il est
ouais il est il a c'est un Afric méth il
a il a un truc de roi quoi c'est un mec
bon alors
Clémentine je dis pas que vous parlez
beaucoup hein mais vous avez un bon
débit he [__] mais si non non je parle
trop c'est pas bienors va
vie sans la bouche on Bou pas P le
jingle bien alors dans un dîner un
producteur très connu vous propose un
rôle très important en vous appelant
Françoise toujours dans ce
dîner arrive votre pire ennemie
mouetez
pas la bouffe est infecte dans ce dîner
à
chier ah enfin [__] je su plus
rigolé alors bon la bouffe est inf fa
vous picolez effectivement un moment bah
vous allez aux toilettes vous vous
trompez de porte et vous tombez sur un
couple deux mecs en train de baiser
oui d'accord à la fin du dîner tout le
monde offre un cadeau au maître de
maison parce qu'en fait ce dîner était
organisé pour son anniversaire et vous
avez rien à lui
offrir ah bon ça
suffit qu'est-ce ça fait alors vous
rentrez chez vous en voiture les flics
vous
arrêtent ils vous reconnaissent pas
il
reconnaiss en arrivant chez vous il y a
une lettre du laboratoire vous êtes
enceinte
Clémentine d'accord vot j vous appelle
il pourra pas vous rejoindre cette nuit
ça fait deux fois cette
semaine à votre
ge pourre s de rien RER YouTube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu